before we start going off into things
outside of our solar system I want to
take a few step back a few steps back
because I found this neat picture of the
Sun over here and the reason why at
least in my mind it's it's kind of
mind-blowing is because at this scale
the Sun is obviously still a a huge
object at this scale the earth would be
roughly and this is an approximation
roughly that big and so for me at least
this is mind-blowing because it's this
idea that our whole planet everything
could fit into one of these kind of
plasma flares coming off of the Sun and
you can only imagine I mean we can't
realistically be there but if you were
in some type of protected capsule what
it would be like to be in this type of
an environment so I just thought this
was kind of a a fascinating concept
well anyway with that out of the way
let's just think about what it means to
be at the boundary of the solar system
in the last video we explored the Oort
belt which was about it started it
started a little under 1 light year away
from the Sun but the depending on what
you view is the boundary of the
socialism' it could be something way
farther in or it could be something as
far out as something like the like the
Oort cloud so if you with if the Sun
right you know we see these things being
ejected but even in unseen ways or
unseen particles super high-energy
electrons electrons and protons are also
being ejected from the Sun at super high
velocities 400 kilometers per second let
me write that down 400 kilometers per
second and on earth we're protected from
these highly energetic particles because
of our magnetic but because of Earth's
magnetic field but if you're on the
surface of the Moon when the Sun is on
top with wood and you're not on the dark
side of the moon and you'll have direct
contact with these and yet as you can
imagine it not not the best thing to
hang around in too long but the whole
reason why I'm even talking about these
these these charged particles that are
coming out of huge velocities from the
surface of Sun these are considered the
solar wind these are the solar solar
wind and I'll put wind in quotes it's
really very different than our
traditional Association of a nice breeze
these are just charged particles that
are going out at super high velocities
from the Sun and I'm even going into the
idea of the solar wind because to some
degree they can help us they can help us
with one definition of maybe the limits
of the solar system and that's the
limits of how far the solar wind is
getting before it kind of comes in
confrontation with the the interstellar
medium and this right here this right
here shows a depiction of that so the
Oort cloud
it was way at least the the edges of the
dense part of it is way outside of this
this is as we saw this is just where
Voyager 1 Voyager 2 if we wanted the
orbit of Siddhant Sedna it would be
something it would be something like
it's the the closed part would be
something over here and then it would go
out but the Oort cloud is much much
further out so if you look at this kind
of view of the solar system as the
extent of the solar wind it's much
smaller than the Oort cloud but it's
still fairly large so this is right here
this Helio Helio pause right here and I
got this from Wikipedia this is
essentially where the the velocity and
the forces of the solar wind are
counteracted counteracted that it's been
the the pressure is so diluted at this
point that is counteracted by mainly the
hydrogen and the helium that's in the
interstellar interstellar kind of medium
that's just kind of out there so this is
you know after this point it's not
really being ejected out anymore it's
kind of being it's there's this kind of
pause I guess you could say and Voyager
1 and Voyager 2 is this I have
essentially gotten pretty close to
people believe that that pause over
there and so that's one view of the
edges of the solar system there's never
going to be any hard edge to it another
view would be something like the Oort
cloud you know the area where you have
the still objects out there and this is
all actually we haven't directly
observed objects in the Oort cloud we
think that they are out there and then
maybe the most abstract definition would
be a significant influence from the
Sun's gravitational pull so all of those
ways are to imagine the extent of the
solar system but they all kind of leave
a gray area for what is and what is not
in the solar system but my whole point
here what I want to do is start explore
a little bit outside of the solar system
and just give you a sense of the scale
as we just go to the closest star so if
we go if we go right over here this
shows our our local neighborhood from a
stellar point of view and even though
these stars look pretty big if you
actually were to draw this this this is
our this is our solar system right here
but clearly it and you know you might be
say oh maybe that's the Sun no the Sun
if you were to draw it here it wouldn't
even make up one pixel in fact the
entire orbit of Pluto everything inside
of it still would not make up one pixel
on the screen right here this what we
see right here what we see right here
which is a radius it's roughly it's
roughly a radius of about of about give
or take a Lightyear this is roughly
maybe the radius of the Oort cloud the
Oort cloud and we saw in the last video
how huge that was especially relative
especially relative to especially
relative to the radius of say Pluto's
orbit which is roughly like that and
that itself is a huge huge diameter or
huge distance away from the Sun and that
wouldn't even make a pixel that wouldn't
even make a pixel on this diagram right
over here but just to give you an idea
just to give you an idea of how far we
are so you know we're a speck of a speck
of a speck inside here and they have a
pixel of a pixel in the center of here
to make it from our solar system or in
particular from from Earth maybe to the
nearest star to the nearest or maybe the
nearest cluster of stars the Alpha
Centauri they're the they're the the
nearest cluster of stars there's three
stars Alpha Centauri a which is the
largest Alpha Centauri B and then
there's one that you can't observe with
the naked eye alpha Proximus or I think
it's Proxima Centauri I think it's what
it's called I don't not alpha Proximus
Proxima Centauri but that's a much
smaller star but that's the closest star
and it's about and this what well you
can view it is this whole this whole
cluster of stars right here and they're
the closest is about 4.2 light-years
light-years away or another way to think
about it if someone were to shine a
light on one of the
planets and assuming that light could
get to us it would take four point two
years to get to us or if these guys just
disappeared or blew up we wouldn't know
it for four point two years and you
might say hey that's not too bad we
should take a trip over there and and
check them out see if there are any
other people there that we can meet and
and and and exchange technologies with
or whatnot but this is a huge distance
just as four point two light-years it's
an unbelievably ridiculous distance and
just to give you a sense the Voyager 1
and 2 we talked about in the last video
and we can even see how far they've
gotten they've gotten pretty much to the
heliopause these guys are traveling at
60,000 kilometers
60,000 kilometers an hour
60,000 kilometers an hour which is the
same thing as 17 kilometers per second
17 kilometers per second if we were able
to get up to those type of velocities
and these guys got up to those type of
velocities by leveraging the
gravitational pull of some of the larger
planets to accelerate and keep
accelerating so this is a pretty hard
velocity to actually reach but if you
were able to reach those that velocity
and go straight in the direction of go
straight in the direction of the Alpha
Centauri system the closest stars to
Earth it would take you it would take
you 80,000 years traveling at the same
velocity as Voyager 1 which is the
fastest of the Voyager so it's a
ridiculously long time so it's going to
be we're going to figure out some some
better way to do that